Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
where Spanish-speaking experts
from Latin America
will show you some
of our tools,
developer products,
APIs and new tricks.
This course is divided
into five parts.
We invite you to watch it
and learn along.
Here we go.
Hi. Welcome back to the
HTML web development
with Google Drive
introduction course.
I'm Cesar Anton Dorantes,
Google Developer Expert
for the Google Drive platform.
In the previous lesson
we learned how to develop
an HTML5 app
hosted in Google Drive,
capable of converting data
into charts using Google Charts.
In this lesson we'll see
the following subjects:
Introduction to
Google Spreadsheets;
Connecting your app
with Google Spreadsheets;
and finally, a practice where
we connect your HTML5 app
with Google's cloud.
Are you ready? Let's go!
INTRODUCTION TO
GOOGLE SPREADSHEETS
Google Spreadsheets
is a spreadsheet app
based on Google's cloud
that presents
several important features
that sets it apart
from other spreadsheet software,
starting with the fact
that no additional software
needs to be installed
to be able to start working,
since Google Spreadsheets runs
straight on your browser.
Another important feature
is that your file is saved
in real time,
therefore there's no need to be
saving all the time anymore.
It also saves a history
of the changes performed
to a document,
including time, date and user
that performed the changes.
Google Spreadsheets
boasts of Google Docs'
characteristic
collaboration tools,
so up to 10 users can work
at the same time
and on the same document,
and they all can see what
the rest are doing in real time.
It even lets you open
a chat window on the right
when several people
are connected simultaneously.
This allows for a much more
efficient and dynamic work flow.
Not only Google Spreadsheets
offers the typical functions
you expect from
a spreadsheet app,
but it also goes beyond
and allows developers
to use those spreadsheets
as databases in the Cloud.
But that's not all, they
stand out from other databases
because the data is easily
visible y editable
at any moment,
even by inexperienced people
on programming
or on databases, which
turns out to be very useful
for companies, since they
don't need to train people
on how to access and edit
the data in the system.
All this considered,
Google Spreadsheets is,
by far, the friendliest
database format until now.
You must be wondering
what its storage limits are,
and it's actually very important
to have that in mind
when a database based on this
system is being implemented.
Google Spreadsheets' latest
version allows you to store
up to 10 million cells
per document,
with a maximum 256 columns
in each sheet.
The platform lets you use
up 40 thousand cells
with formulas to calculate
its contents,
and 50 cells importing their
data from external sources.
In case you exceed
any of these limits,
your sheet will stop
taking in new data,
to avoid the loss of them.
It's worth noting that if
a sheet is too big,
it could show a lower
performance than expected,
so it's not recommended
to use them as databases
for big volumes of information.
If your project requires
a broader database,
I recommend you try some
of Google's other databases,
like Script DB or DataStore.
Remember you always have
the highly advisable option
of doing programmatic backups
for your databases
on a Google Spreadsheet.
This is possible by using
Google App Script,
which includes an extensive
function library
specially designed to work
with Spreadsheets,
as well as several methods
to import
your external data sources.
CONNECTING YOUR APP
WITH GOOGLE SPREADSHEETS
An interesting feature
for developers
is that Spreadsheets lets us
publish the spreadsheets
on the Internet transformed
into different formats,
which allows us to choose
the one that bets adapts
to our needs.
The supported formats now
are web page,
HTML code to insert in a page,
comma-separated values,
.txt, PDF, Atom,
RSS, Microsoft Excel
and Open Document
spreadsheets.
Now that you know
the options to publish
a Spreadsheet, it's time to put
your knowledge to the test.
For that we'll use the app
we created in lesson 2,
but we'll replace the part
in which we manually declared
the data with a method
that allows us to import them
from Google Spreadsheets.
You will be surprised
with how easy it is to do it.
First we need to create
a new Spreadsheet,
which we use to save
the information
we're going to pass to our app.
You can do it from
Google Drive's web app
by clicking on "Create" and
then choosing "spreadsheet."
You can also create it
by entering
docs.google.com/spreadsheet.
In order to use a Spreadsheet
as a database
you need to publish it first.
For this, go to File menu
and pick "Publish on the Web."
This will lead you to the
publishing on the Web options.
The first thing to do is click
on "Start publishing,"
then just copy the address
that shows up
down on the "Obtaining a link
to published data" section.
The information obtained
by this mean
is updated approximately
every 5 minutes.
Should you need
updated-by-the-second data,
you'll need to create a Google
App Script JSONP servlet.
I invite you to Google
on how to create these backends
for your web apps.
For this lesson's example,
feel free to use the address
that is shown onscreen,
which contains the chart
I'm using for the example.
Notice that if you open it
straight with your browser,
you'll see a representation
of the chart data.
If you want to see the example
chart from Spreadsheets,
use the address that is
now being shown onscreen.
It is now time
to start programming.
I recommend you use the code
we built in lesson 2
and just apply the changes
on JavaScript.
Remember that code-recycling
is a highly recommended practice
and Visualization API
is designed so your code
is easily recyclable.
Since the change
we're going to apply
will only be on our app's logic,
we just need to modify
a few lines
in the file charts.js
we built in last lesson.
We first create a new function
called handleQueryResponse,
to which we'll assign
the argument (response.)
Remember arguments
are for importing
external data to our function
when we're calling it.
Let's now pass all the contents
of function drawVisualization
to our new function,
handleQueryResponse.
In drawVisualization,
let's add a variable called
"query," which
we'll use to import
and store our external data.
In order to do so, you just need
to use the command
new google.visualization.Query
and put in the parenthesis
the address published
for the Spreadsheet, whose data
we want to import.
Now, let's pass the data
we imported from query
to our function
handleQueryResponse.
Nailing this is as easy
as putting the variable's name,
in this case, query, followed
by the command "send"
and between parenthesis,
the function to which
we'll pass the data,
in this case,
handleQueryResponse.
Time to delete the data
we manually declared
in last lesson and to replace
them with the dynamic data
we just programmed.
For this, we'll delete
everything in the variable data
and we will put instead
the argument response
and we will add the method
getDataTable.
Although our app
is ready to run,
every time we call data
from an external source,
it is advisable to add a method
that sounds an alarm
in case something goes wrong.
To do so, in the beginning
of the function
handleQueryResponse we add
a simple "if" that triggers
in case there is an error
and to alerts the user
by using window. alert.
That's it. Our app can now
receive data in real time
from a Google Spreadsheet.
It was quite easy, wasn't it?
PRACTICE: CONNECTING YOUR APP
WITH GOOGLE'S CLOUD
I invite you to watch
this lesson again,
this time pausing it
to follow the steps
and copy the code
that is shown.
For a comparison, you can see
an already built example
by entering to:
Once your app works correctly,
I suggest you make a Spreadsheet
with your personal info
about how you usually
distribute your day
and connect it to your app.
If you wish to share
your new baby with the world,
I invite you to post
its address on Twitter
next to the hash tag
Hackademy Drive.
This will be it for now.
See you next time with:
"Using the G+ Login button
for HTML5 sites and apps,"
when we'll learn
how to make our app
show the login button
when a user
hasn't signed in
with his Google account.
I say goodbye for now
but remember:
keep on programming!